welcome to this video playing only X one
of the more frequent opponents from
Turkey and I am we cut them yeah maybe
play it let's let's for change play the
balloon see what happens golden opening
Berlin defense one of them check the
weapons that Magnus Carlsen used in the
world championship match to to
neutralize 1.e4 and I think really am as
mentioned in those videos that I'm
produced for him for the World
Championship match I think of that are
not ready should have played d4 earlier
but he stick to you for for quite a
while let's see Bishop to e6 yeah it's
one of them one rather typical position
of the Berlin he played b3 and ce4
usually this is a successful black if
that happens because a b3 is a potential
weakness that my bishop later coming to
f5 to see to that the bishop can use in
fact that the tournament game once
against a very decent field master we're
at the end I really managed to win with
Bishop see to all the porns really all
of them it's quite quite funny ok so the
only problem as usual in the Berlin is a
hack I have not castled and mugs don't
don't play I mean both rooks I can one
has exchanged anthem yeah let's go here
yes yes the sir play with their form
it's a this is interesting how to play
now he's got f5 a d6 this is Sir this is
dangerous no doubt should I play rook g8
yeah the Berlin sometimes is really no
ugly opening ok let's get rid of a bit
of material and I think f5 a d6 is
really a problem so maybe I need to
cover g7 prophylactically yeah the funny
thing is that this might be excellent
for white really I'm not sure but it can
easily turn to to being to being
problematic if this turns out to be over
extensional at the end membership grabs
grabs the material hmm wait wait wait
wait there should be seven I mean he's
he's running into a pin here and now I
wonder hmm i played g6 a threatened to
take and maybe play rook g3 okay let's
try that if he takes rook takes my look
is playing suddenly
and interesting it game okay that take
now ok Knight f6 is not not a problem
and suddenly i'm i'm on the g file take
here I mean rook g2 I mean this looks
nice
the applicant certainly an excellent
shape suddenly my look and everything is
activated this is a really tricky
opening so let's see that any direct way
to make use of the slightly off
coordination
Group C 2 or no creo que h2 maybe just
picking up the palm okay let's let's try
that there's also see three hanging so
rook takes King moves Bishop b4 and c3
faults
yeah the balloon sir is a good opening
what can you say it's just not easy at
all for white hmm that take sugar kingi
for probably
anything better i taking e 4 and taking
age three and not sure that this is
winning
ok conking g4 I can go back to oh it's
not going for that I but now i can i can
go to the i can go to the look at camera
click here take here this looks like too
much i go here takes takes King e7 hmm
should I have played it differently okay
but um check check check ok
he's very active mm-hmm very active I
can I can get all the spawns but he can
take c7 until he's got this rook
supporting the pawn okay
already a bit down on time so just be
content with them what I have okay how
to to do that now
hmm
okay i'll just take the six porn
this King is so is cut off back thus I
should have prevented really who know
this this will be enough probably
time warning yeah that's it's not enough
he's in time czech teen drama oh I'm not
in good shape at the moment really to
not win this is quite heartbreaking I
mean this is probably yeah what is it
minus 4 yeah there there probably are
better ways Brooke age 18 resigns yeah
I'm just missing so many easy moves at
the moment just yeah and oh and over man
this end game is also very good but
maybe he's got enough counter play this
is a quite chat white substantial chat
check of course rook to e3 just ripped
III yeah this should should actually win
rather easily oops no not that one hit
this one of course and then I take he
six next move went to keep both covered
his king is in my camp but cut off and
at the end of this pawn will win yeah
lost lost him lost many many
opportunities I didn't take him I mean
at this stage really looked like um like
a threatening position with their 5 and
so on but then he ran into this self pin
and TM I don't know this is probably a
mistake every King f4f 60 hmm after that
black is just in great shape I didn't
capitalize on that just the draw okay
thanks for watching